why do writers get stuck why do writers
get stuck well you want to have a good
outline writers get stuck sometimes
because they you know they come up with
a great idea and they immediately start
writing the idea which is fine but at
some point you're gonna want to stop and
do some kind of an outline and here's
the thing is that this is where writers
will go yeah but I heard that Woody
Allen never outlines and Charlie Kaufman
never outlines and the truth is they do
they probably just don't write their
outline down but they have been writing
stories for such a long time and they've
been and they probably actually do have
lots of notes but they've been doing
that they have developed such an Menino
story structures become second nature
for them they've become masters and so
they are naturally seeing they're
naturally connected to this this process
but I would think the main reason
writers get stuck is because they're not
working off some kind of an outline it
could be even the most you know
rudimentary outline but you have to have
something to work from or here's the
irony is that if you don't have an
outline you're actually going to lose
confidence when you get to a point where
you start to feel stuck because you're
always going to get stuck at some point
in the process but if you've got some
kind of basic sense of you're the story
structure or basic sense of the movement
you can actually get excited about the
point where you get stuck because you
know where the story is going to go and
that's where you can start to move in
all you can you you you can kind of
relax into the panic and let your
characters speak to you and go in
directions that you had never imagined
that are actually going to often support
where the story wants to go okay that's
why I would say if you know you're gonna
left go right okay so so if I know this
is gonna happen let me explore the
complete opposite and relax in the fact
that I'm gonna get to where I'm going
it's just not going I'm not gonna arrive
there in the same way I thought I was
going to thinking of like the firm you
know Tom Cruise and then that moment
when well I don't want to give any
spoilers away but I don't think you give
me thirty year old so I'm just thinking
of the living room scene where he comes
back and and the partners are there and
and maybe I'm pushing oh yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah right
and totally different than this is where
this is where Robert Towne I love this
Robert Towne adapted the firm okay and
he because I always thought a great
novel except the ending felt like a
total cheat because mitch mcdeere ends
up on a sailboat with ten million
dollars and and and he's like in the
Cayman Islands or something like that
and he's not a lawyer anymore but he
wanted to be a lawyer he loved being a
lawyer and so robert towne he read it
and he was like well wait a second why
can't he still be a lawyer at the end of
the story but have a transformation and
so he in the living room scene it's been
decades since I've seen this movie but
the living room scene is where he
confronts the is it that is it the
mobsters and the I believe so I think
isn't his wife there too in the isn't
maybe I'm picturing to your from story
but what he does what he basically does
is he says I'm a lawyer and I work for
you the mob but I also have all your
and if anything happens to me you
guys are and so that's what you
know John Grisham didn't do but that's
what makes Robert Towne a genius is
because he understands story structure
he understands transformation I mean
John Grisham is brilliant I love John
Grisham but that the ending of
that felt like a cop-out to me because
he just he just goes off into into like
like that ending is actually a tragedy
he's now gonna spend the rest of his
life in hiding in in the novel in the
Cayman Islands in hiding with ten
million dollars that sounds like a
nightmare I don't want to wants that
life but because he doesn't get to you
know he's gonna be in hiding but the way
Robert Towne did it was was masterful
because it he was true to the dramatic
question that was about a guy who was an
idealistic lawyer who takes a job for a
dirty firm and ends up in a horror show
and he fight and he manages a way to
climb out and outsmart you know the
villains brilliant
you